Transcription: Marion Peiffert
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Je viens vous partager ma méthode
pour en finir avec le tabou.
Je m’appelle Rita Sekkat
et  j’ai fondé une ONG internationale
qui lutte contre la précarité menstruelle.
Pour l’exercice,
vous l’avez compris,
nous allons parler de règles.
Oui, oui, de menstruations.
Bon, je crois que j’ai mis
une bonne ambiance.
Le sujet met tout le monde à l’aise.
On va pouvoir commencer.
Vous savez, c’est pas trop
les  “beurk, c’est sale”
que j’ai le plus entendu.
Ça, les gens savent
qu’on peut plus trop le dire.
En revanche, vous savez,
ces expressions pour qualifier la chose
sans jamais prononcer le nom ?
Très important de ne jamais
prononcer le nom quand on parle de tabou.
Vous voyez de quoi je veux parler ?
Les “ragnagnas”, les “trucs de filles”...
Ou mieux, la réaction du mec, vous savez :
« Non, je veux rien savoir. »
D’ailleurs pour la séquence
“Le saviez-vous” du jour :
le sang des règles,
c’est le même pH, la même composition
que le sang d’une blessure de foot.
Donc ce n’est pas plus sale.
Bon, revenons à notre sujet.
Pour lutter contre
la précarité menstruelle,
on commence par quoi ?
On commence par déconstruire
le tabou, les idées reçues.
Les “ça pue”, “c’est impur”.
Ça, c’est les gentils.
Je viendrai à ce que j’ai pu entendre
d’un peu plus pimenté tout à l’heure.
Des croyances qui empêchent les femmes
de s’épanouir dans leur nature de femme.
Dans le cas précis des règles,
si on ignore sa propre nature,
comment s’émanciper ?
Ben oui, pour s’émanciper, il faut
commencer par s’accepter soi-même.
Et s’accepter soi-même
commence par se connaître soi-même.
Comment tout cela fonctionne ?
Il y a quoi sous le capot ?
Si j'ai choisi cette image,
ce n'est pas par hasard.
Vous allez peut-être vous reconnaître,
mais on a déjà tous fait un truc :
quand on tombe en panne sur l’autoroute,
on descend de la voiture,
on ouvre le capot,
on met les mains sur les hanches,
c’est très important de mettre
les mains sur les hanches,
on regarde le moteur et on se met
à expliquer ce qui ne va pas,
à parler, à parler,
alors qu’on n’y connaît rien.
La plupart du temps, on n'y connaît rien.
Et ça, messieurs dames, ça porte un nom.
C’est ce qu’on appelle
l’ultracrépidarianisme.
Parler très bien de ce qu’on ignore.
On parle de tout, on sait tout.
De nos jours, on a beaucoup
de champions dans le domaine.
Alors…
En fait, comme le sujet est tabou,
personne ne l’étudie.
Comme personne ne l’étudie,
cela laisse la place à n’importe qui
pour dire n’importe quoi.
Et c’est comme ça que les idées fausses
s’installent dans notre société.
En fait que ce soit pour les fake news
ou pour les idées reçues,
on y croit parce que quelque part,
c’est plus facile, plus réconfortant.
Alors, bon…
Parlons peu, parlons bien.
Je suis venue
pour vous partager ma méthode.
Donc je vous propose de faire
maintenant l’exercice ensemble
de la déconstruction du tabou.
Alors par quoi on commence ?
Étape une :
je vais essayer de créer une relation
de confiance entre vous et moi.
Je vais essayer de briser la glace
en vous demandant par exemple
de vous présenter.
Ou en vous demandant de me parler de vous.
En fait, l’objectif de cette étape,
c’est que vous puissiez vous sentir
libre de vous exprimer
sans craindre d’être jugé,
sans craindre d’être exclu du groupe.
Bon, une fois que tout le monde
est en confiance, on peut passer
à notre deuxième étape.
vous vous auto-questionnez.
Demandez-vous, dans votre tête,
sans parler à votre voisin,
demandez vous : qu’est-ce qui fait
que ce sujet est tabou ?
Qu’est-ce qui fait que quelque part,
je ne suis pas très à l’aise
à l’idée d’en parler ?
Demandez-vous également,
qu’est-ce que vous
savez ou croyez savoir du sujet ?
Allez-y, faites l’exercice,
je vous laisse quelques secondes.
Réfléchissez bien.
Je vois que ça réfléchit.
En fait,
remarquez que pour la première fois,
vous avez peut être listé dans votre tête
les “pourquoi ce sujet est tabou” et
les “qu’est-ce que je sais” ?
Et rien qu’avec ces deux questions,
vous venez de faire 99% du travail.
99% du travail, rendez-vous compte!
Rien qu’avec ces deux questions !
Cette étape est vraiment cruciale.
On va pouvoir passer à la troisième étape.
Étape trois.
Je vais vous demander de formuler
ce que vous avez pensé.
On va commencer par :
pourquoi ce sujet est tabou.
Alors dites-moi,
pourquoi ce sujet est tabou ?
C’est en quelque sorte intime.
Le sang ça fait peur.
Je vois qu’il y a beaucoup de pudeur,
on est dans le sujet.
En fait, moi, ce qui m’a beaucoup marqué
de mon expérience terrain, c’est notamment
une jeune fille qui m’avait pris
en aparté d’un atelier de travail
et qui m’avait dit tout bas :
« Écoutez, Madame, je peux pas trop
en parler parce que c’est “hchouma” ».
“Hchouma”.
En fait “hchouma”,
ça veut dire honteux
dans le dialecte marocain.
Pour comprendre d’où cela vient,
il faut qu’on puisse opposer
ces croyances, cette croyance,
mettre en perspective
la définition du tabou.
Qu’est-ce qu’un tabou ?
Un tabou,
c’est un système d’interdiction religieux
appliqué à ce qui est considéré
comme sacré ou impur.
Autrement dit, ce sur quoi on fait
silence par crainte ou pudeur.
Allons alors plus loin.
Ça veut dire que le tabou est
finalement lié à la culture locale.
Je m’y attache, je m’y reconnais
parce que quelque part,
j’y reconnais ma culture, mes valeurs.
Je veux vous emmener encore plus loin.
Dites moi maintenant, qu’est-ce que
vous pensez savoir du sujet ?
Allez-y, je vous écoute.
Bon, ben, comme quoi c’est vraiment tabou.
Moi ce qui m’a particulièrement marquée
encore une fois sur le terrain,
c’est notamment une question.
Une jeune fille qui m’avait pris encore
une fois en aparté
et qui m’avait dit en chuchotant :
« Madame, est-ce que c’est vrai
qu’il faut pas prendre sa douche
pendant les règles ? »
Parce que sinon les mauvais esprits
entre en nous, le “Sheitan” ? »
Le “Sheitan”, le diable.
Rendez-vous compte du degré
d’irrationalité dans ces croyances !
Ou encore : les règles ça arrive
à jour fixe, à date fixe, dès le départ.
Un peu comme les impôts.
D’ailleurs sur cette dernière croyance,
Une histoire qui m’a
particulièrement touchée,
c’était une jeune femme
qui s’appelait Anissa.
Et qui m’a raconté encore
la voix un peu tremblotante.
Elle me disait “Écoute, moi,
quand j’avais douze, treize ans,
j’ai eu mes règles.
Et puis, pendant plusieurs mois,
je ne les ai pas eues.
Et mes parents m’ont virée de la maison
parce qu’ils pensaient
que j’étais enceinte alors que
je n’étais pas mariée. »
Virée de la maison. Douze-treize ans.
En fait, Anissa n'était pas enceinte.
Son cycle menstruel n’était
juste pas encore réglé.
Ses parents ne l’auraient pas virée
s’ils avaient été instruits.
Cela nous amène au fait que finalement,
le tabou ne va pas être le même en France,
au Maroc ou au Sénégal.
Alors vous allez me dire,
à très juste titre,
mais comment faire
pour déconstruire le tabou
aussi bien en France
qu’au Maroc ou au Sénégal ?
Alors attention...
Grâce à cet homme : René.
Oui, oui, René Descartes.
En adoptant un discours
neutre, objectif, scientifique,
basé sur des faits démontrés,
pour aboutir à la vérité.
Autrement dit,
tout ce qui est vrai reste vrai
jusqu'à ce qu'on prouve le contraire
par des faits démontrés,
par des sources fiables
ou par la vérification de ses pairs.
Bon, vous allez me dire que c'est évident,
c'est de la bienpensance.
Mais c’est quand même
important de le rappeler.
Il faut opposer, à l’ère des “fake news”,
la vérité vérifiable.
Alors quoi de plus implacable
que d’adopter un discours
scientifique et objectif ?
Eh bien, il faut d'abord que vous ayez
l'intention sincère de m'écouter.
Il faut d’abord
que vous acceptiez progressivement
de vous détacher de vos idées reçues.
Et c’est là où on arrive
à notre quatrième étape.
Étape quatre : vous m’écoutez
parce que je vous ai écouté.
En fait, en créant
une relation de confiance,
en vous laissant vous exprimer,
sans juger aucune de vos idées,
j’ai créé cette intention
sincère de m’écouter.
Et là seulement, je peux utiliser
le discours de la méthode.
Mon discours neutre et objectif.
Parce qu’à ce moment-là,
mon discours n’est plus vu comme
un discours prosélyte et militant,
mais bien comme un discours
scientifique et amical.
Alors reprenons l'exemple d'Anissa
qui a été virée de chez elle.
En fait, elle ne l’aurait jamais été
si ses parents avaient été instruits.
Ça nous montre que finalement,
l’accès à la dignité
n’est pas détachable
de l’instruction collective.
Et que l’instruction collective
ne peut se faire que sur la base
du discours de la méthode.
En fait, quand on utilise
le discours de la méthode,
ce discours scientifique et objectif,
que ce soit au fin fond de la montagne
ou au fin fond du désert,
il se passe une chose implacable
avec les jeunes filles.
Plus on déconstruit
le tabou avec précision,
plus elles s’en libèrent.
Plus elles s’en libèrent,
plus les familles s’en libèrent.
Plus les familles s’en libèrent,
plus le vœu de se libérer augmente.
Et voilà qu’on entre
dans un cercle vertueux collectif.
Alors vous allez me dire
que d’une civilisation à l’autre,
d’un pays à l’autre,
d’une culture à l’autre,
les moyens d’atteindre la dignité
ne sont pas les mêmes.
Et vous avez raison.
Et si les moyens changent, la finalité,
à savoir la dignité, reste identique.
Autrement dit, s’il existe
plusieurs chemins dans la montagne,
il n’y a qu’un seul sommet : la dignité.
Alors maintenant,
faisons l’exercice inverse.
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passerait
si on n’utilisait pas
le discours de la méthode ?
Si on n’utilisait pas ce discours
neutre et scientifique ?
Eh bien, chaque groupe voudra
défendre les moyens et non la finalité.
Chaque groupe s’opposera
par principe à mon discours
parce qu’il le verra comme
une attaque envers sa culture.
D’où l’intérêt
de la médiation interculturelle
basée sur le discours de la méthode
pour déconstruire les tabous.
On en arrive à notre cinquième
et dernière étape.
Vous vous rendez peut-être compte
que vous êtes trompés
sur ce qu’il fallait défendre.
En fait, en déconstruisant le tabou,
je n’attaque pas votre culture,
je n’attaque pas vos valeurs,
je n’attaque pas vos traditions,
je déconstruis simplement une idée
pour permettre aux jeunes femmes
de retrouver leur dignité.
Mais à ce moment là, vous devenez
peut-être, à votre tour,
ambassadeur de la cause.
Parce que plus fort vous aurez été
dupés par le tabou,
plus forte sera votre envie
de les déconstruire à nouveau.
Bon, je vois que je vous ai
assommés d’informations,
donc je vous propose de récapituler.
Comment déconstruire un tabou ?
Étape une :
vous créez une relation de confiance
avec votre auditoire.
Étape deux :
vous l’invitez
à réfléchir sur pourquoi
ce sujet est tabou
et qu’est ce qu’il croit savoir du sujet.
Étape trois :
vous lui demandez de formuler
ce qu’il a pensé.
Étape quatre :
L’autre vous écoute parce
que vous l’avez écouté.
Et là seulement, vous utilisez
le discours de la méthode.
Cinquième et dernière étape :
L’autre se rend peut-être compte
qu’il s’est trompé
sur ce qu’il fallait défendre.
Et il devient peut-être à son tour
ambassadeur de la cause.
Alors cette méthode
que je vous ai partagée aujourd’hui
et qui, de mon humble expérience,
fonctionne, franchement,
satisfait ou remboursé, ça fonctionne.
Cette méthode s’applique aussi bien
aux tabous qui touchent
la dignité des hommes
qu’aux tabous qui touchent
la dignité des femmes.
À votre tour maintenant de l’utiliser
à votre manière, à votre échelle,
pour briser toutes les omertas
qui persistent dans notre monde.
Merci.